this fruitcake is what connects all of
us we're gonna get a lot of sweetness
from the dried fruits and that crunch
from the nuts whenever i bite into it
just feels like home hi i'm jessica and
today i'm gonna show you how to make
filipino fruit cake filipino fruit cake
is almost like a cross between a cake
and a banana bread but with raisins and
nuts and all these different types of
fruits we soak the raisins and the sweet
wines so they get super plump and juicy
this recipe is much milder it's very
family friendly with the egg whites
you're going to go to work out for your
arms you want to get stiff peaks the
fruitcake isn't an asian or
traditionally filipino dessert this
recipe is originally from my
great-grandmother and she pass it down
to the different children in her family
each family makes it a little bit
differently not everybody likes fruit
cake and i'm just like well if you've
had my grandma's fruit cake you would
like it i'm sorry if you didn't have
good fruit cake in your life stop
bashing fruitcake
now we're gonna gradually add in the
flowers so it's gonna be smooth and not
clumpy look at that bright yellow color
it's like the sun my grandmother would
be the one to make fruitcake every year
but now that she's 90 she's kind of
passed it on to my uncle and so he'd
have an army of people with him in the
kitchen making fruitcake and my
grandmother's the general and if my
grandma says that the fruitcake tastes
good that is a great compliment this is
where my grandma supervises my uncle
fold it with love fold it with love i
know it's super hard but that's how it's
supposed to feel you're supposed to work
your muscles just imagine my grandma
making this for 50 years if a grandma
can do it you can do it christmas is a
really big thing for the philippines and
we usually have more traditional
filipino desserts like
and usually we buy them from a street
vendor and it's served warm filipinos go
all out for christmas lights are
everywhere there's christmas trees
everywhere september 1st christmas
starts we're going to stick this in the
oven bake it low and slow
just so it's cooked very gently when you
move to a totally different culture you
get super super homesick i come from a
very big family and we're all super
close but we've moved to different parts
of the world so this fruitcake is what
connects all of us whenever i bite into
it just feels like cold this fruitcake
is super important to our family and it
just wouldn't feel like christmas
without it
it's like i'm 10 years old again it's so
good
oh yes
i'm sure my grandma's gonna judge how i
make this fruit cake but that's okay
it's gonna taste good
and that's what matters